vabbè ma quando già la partenza capisci
che è una gran giornata
beh a tutti ragazzi pervenute questo
video sono parigi oggi siamo su it e sto
tizio col palloncino e inter game va
bene hanno fatto i mini già ovviamente
un fan made suo gioco non è un gioco
ufficiale sa bene entrano fatto in tempo
alle già inglese ti puoi loro parlo a mo
di renzi
ancora peggio ho trovato una pala
richiede boxes to view internamente ok
ha quindi posso trovare cose dentro le
le altre cose che figo mi sembra un
sacco di house vi ricordate di austera
finissimo si terra la palla pala la pala
per scavare dentro una scatola tra
l'altro giustamente e che ci ho trovato
niente o una torcia
mi chiamano va neanche capito ma in
tutto questo cosa c'entra spiegami ho
trovato il frammento di qualcosa non ho
idea di che cosa sia ma va bene e
sicuramente ce ne sarà ancora una eccolo
qua dietro la testa di un animatronic
sembra ma sono orbo come la morte io ce
l'avevo visto mai o aver tuo verde sai
che più che farmi paura tu mi fa paura
il tizio di sé ma che colloca frate 1827
credo sia
il pass con 182 e ho trovato tua madre
beh ragazzi ho trovato sicuramente
questo this item nizza place questo
oggetto ha bisogno di un posto
cosa vuol dire che bisogna lo posso se
se porgere lo se tolgo maronna roux
carmen è però vabbè
tu stai fermo che ti ammazzo credo che
ci sia del senso dietro tutto questo
senso che io non vedo e per carità però
sono sicuro che c'è
usiamo la chiave per aprire la scatola
bella posso bloccare con videocamera e
la madonna use the work is to move ha
quindi posso anche muovermi non c'è solo
il gioco con cui si muove l'uscita dei
ragazzi
salve a questo un accendino ai perché
sulla siga no perché io non fumo però
era per darti fuoco amico mio ascoltami
e so che abbiamo iniziato col piede
sbagliato soffrire qua stai fermo
eva per quanti il concetto che monterà
action porta [ __ ] me l'aspettavo mai
c'è un po me l'aspettavo ma non me
l'aspettavo adesso è simpatico questo
gioco quando le creature si fanno troppo
vicine usa l'accendino
io li posso iniziare a ecco perfetto vai
vai vai apri apri apri la bocca vai vai
veloce la celaschi quanto tempo per
aprirla può torna che noi che mani
brutte che ci hai molli proprio regalo
lo funziona sta cosa
aiuto
non sta funzionando poco però è un
casino perché non devo avere un tempismo
incredibile cosa che io non ho mai avuto
nella mia vita
grande mamma mia
maledetti haters che come messi uno si
dovrebbe cadere addosso se ti fai così
c'è scritto
spiegami con il problema l'ho fatta se
vuol dire se tu prevende cresce in sé
vabbè hayden sic
sì ma che cazzo è la divina commedia
inglese io gioco senza le istruzioni io
riesco io forte click and hold to lift e
successo a san diapositive figo su di sé
lift lifting della versace click and
roll to lift me up e serve solo per
aprire e far
la tua sorella morta ieri più lift the
garage d'or while pennywise absent
fronte progetto di mega teens hayden
chirico quindi se apri la porta mentre
pennywise che sarebbe it non è presente
nelle immagini potrebbe entrare e uscire
articoli non devo aprire la porta se non
vedo penny wise nelle nelle diapositive
che se tu vedi penny wise o qualsiasi
altra cosa innaturale immediatamente
aprì la porta del garage e aspetta che
il proiettore proietti la prossima
immagine se non sei abbastanza veloce ti
ucciderà bene a cielo anche una creatura
nel dipinto di dietro alla madonna
quanta roba il suo gioco c'è pure una
quindi io devo guardare diapositive e
vedere che non ci sia penny wise sono mi
salta addosso bene allo stesso tempo
devo guardare che la creatura del
dipinto non mi venga addosso e la
creatura del dipinto come che la scaccio
via me lo spieghi tu però fino adesso
non c'era pennywise e nelle diapositive
quindi direi che va tutto bene poi anche
difficile perché le proietta su un muro
di legna per tutti sti segnetti stupidi
e non capisco più niente
c'è un casino ruspa ruspa c'è un palo c
c'era un palloncino ha fatto bene vero
ho visto un palloncino in tempo la
creatura del dipinto eccola qua c'è la
casuale dipinto cosa faccio però era
creatore dipinto la vedo cosa faccio per
mandarla via che è sparita c'è qua qua
non c'è niente di strano in storia che
questa ha proseguito
qua mi sa che apro la guarda ma è pronto
sto dubbio è ero indeciso se aprire o
meno però forse è meglio che apro questa
continua a esser ferma quindi va bene
esatto cavata che ansia aiuto
beh vabbè basta ricoperto faccio prima a
regalo 17 to the change cep e nicolais
come si chiama ok mi cerca un attimo
strada tua sorella che caga che caga
vaffan cuore viper non me l'aspettavo ma
io l'ho aperta e non in tempo ma quasi
quindi deve aprirsi proprio tutta o una
nana nana a banana o ucciso it quel
palloncino into culo
fig però mi deve dare il tempo di vedere
l'immagine io che cosa ne so qua è tutto
rosa e vabbè ma quasi sempre lega è tu
stai fermo che ti ammazzo madonna apri
apri apri veloce ma ormai sono più
quelle dove c'è che quelle dove non c'è
quanto sta diventando il vice basta
torna ok o stai fermo
ok ora che la basta veramente sottile
esempio sono in paradiso non c'è niente
dopo il web survive er.it ritorna è
sopravvissuta ritorno di tema
ritorneranno di 27 anni l'ho letto con
un inglese che renzi mi farebbe così
però è stato di un ansiolitico che non
avete idea sul finale veramente peggiori
fai niente il freddy se non sto
scherzando mi veniva l'ansia in una
maniera incredibile veramente figo
presso non minigioco proprio degli ufo
plain elevate happy halloween
vabbè però ragazzi che vi sia piaciuto
costo di 200 comitato mi piace anche a
verso cercando di notizie sono
resistenti
ci vediamo l'anno prossimo arrivo da
ragazzi
[Musica]